what I'd like to introduce you to in
this video is the idea of a linear
equation and just to start ourselves out
let's look at some examples of linear
equations so for example the equation y
is equal to 2x minus 3 this is a linear
equation now why do we call it a linear
equation well if you were to take the
set of all the XY pairs that satisfy
this equation and if you were to graph
them on the coordinate plane you would
actually get a line that's why it's
called a linear equation let's let's
actually feel good about that statement
let's see if let's plot some of the XY
XY pairs that satisfy this equation and
then feel good that it does indeed
generate a line so I'm just going to
pick some X values that make it easy to
calculate the corresponding Y values so
if X is equal to 0 you're going to Y is
going to be 2 times 0 minus 3 which is
negative 3 and on our coordinate plane
here that's we're going to move 0 in the
X direction 0 in the horizontal
direction we're going to go down 3 in
the vertical direction in the Y
direction so that's that point there if
X is equal to 1 what is y equal 2 well 2
times 1 is 2 minus 3 is negative 1
so we move positive 1 in the X direction
and negative 1 or down 1 in the Y
direction now let's see if X is equal to
2 what is Y 2 times 2 is 4 minus 3 is 1
when X is equal to 2 y is equal to 1 and
hopefully you're seeing now that if I
were to keep going and I encourage you
to if you want pause the video try x
equals 3 or x equals negative 1 and keep
going you will see that this is going to
generate a line and in fact let me
connect these dots and you will see you
will see the line that I'm talking about
so let me see if I can draw I'm going to
use the line tool here try to connect
the dots as neatly as I can
there you go this line that I have just
drawn this is the graph this is the
graph of y is equal to 2x minus 3
so if you were to graph all of the XY
pairs that satisfy this equation you are
going to get this line and you might be
saying anyway wait hold on Sal you just
tried some particular points why don't I
just get a bunch of points how do I
actually get a line well I just tried
over here I just try to integer values
of X but you could try any value in
between here all of these it's actually
a pretty neat concept any value of x
that you input into this you find the
corresponding value for y it will sit on
this line so for example for example if
we were to take X is equal to actually
let's say X is equal to negative 0.5 so
if X is equal to negative 0.5 if we look
at the line when X is equal to negative
0.5 it looks like it looks like Y is
equal to negative 4 that looks like that
sits on the line well let's verify that
if X is equal to negative I'll write
that as negative 1/2 then what is y
equal to let's see 2 times negative 1/2
I'll try it out 2 times negative 2 times
negative 1/2 minus 3 well this is 2
times negative 1/2 is negative 1 minus 3
is indeed negative 4 it is indeed
negative 4 so you can literally take any
any for any x value that you put here in
the corresponding Y value it is going to
sit on the line this point right over
here represents a solution to this
linear equation let me just in a color
you can see so this point represents a
solution to a linear equation this point
represents a solutions linear equation
this point is not a solution to the
linear equation so if X is equal to 5
then Y is not going to be equal to 3 if
X is going to be equal to 5 you go to
the line to see what the solution the
linear equation is if X is 5 this shows
us that Y is going to be 7 and it's
indeed the fact that's indeed the case 2
times 5 is 10 minus 3 is 7 the point the
point 5 comma 7 is on or it satisfies
this linear equation so if you take all
of the XY pairs that satisfy it you get
a line that is why it's called a linear
equation
now this isn't the only way that we
could write a linear equation you could
write a linear equation like let me do
this in a new color
you could write a linear equation like
this 4x minus 3y is equal to 12 this
also is a linear equation and we can see
that if we were to graph the XY pairs
that satisfy this we get once again get
a line x and y if X is equal to 0 then
this goes away and you have negative 3y
is equal to 12
see if negative 3y equals 12 then Y
would be equal to negative 4 negative 0
comma negative 4 you can verify that 4
times 0 minus 3 times negative 4 well
that's going to be equal to positive 12
and let's see if Y were to equal 0 if Y
we're to equal 0 then this is going to
be 4 times X is equal to 12
well then X is equal to 3 and so you
have the point 0 comma negative 4 0
comma negative 4 on this line and you
have the point 3 comma 0 on this line 3
comma 0 did I do that right yet so 0
comma negative 4 and then 3 comma 0
these are both going to be on this line
3 comma 0 is also on this line so this
is this line is going to look something
like something like I'll just try to
hand draw it something like that so once
again all of the X Y all the XY pairs
that satisfy this if you were to plot
them out it forms a line now what are
some examples of maybe you're saying
well the way we isn't any equation a
linear equation and the simple answer is
no not any equation is a linear equation
I'll give you some examples of nonlinear
equations so a non nonlinear whoops need
to write a little bit neater than that
non linear equations well those could
include something like Y is equal to x
squared if you graph this you will see
that this is going to be a curve it
could be something like x times y is
equal to 12 this is also not going to be
a line or it could be something like 5
over X plus y is equal to 10 this also
is not going to be a line so now at some
point you could I encourage you to try
to graph these things these are actually
quite interesting but given that we've
now seen examples of linear equations
and nonlinear equations let's see if we
can come up with a definition for linear
equations one way to think about it is
it's an equation that if you were to
graph all the X and y pairs that satisfy
this equation you'll get a line and
that's actually literally where the word
linear equation comes from but another
way to think about it is it's going to
be an equation where every term is
either going to be a constant so for
example 12 is a constant it's not going
to change based on the value of some
variable 12 is 12 or negative 3 is
negative 3 so every term is either going
to be a constant or it's going to be a
constant times a variable raised to the
first power so this is the constant two
times X to the first power this is the
variable Y raised to the first power you
could say this is just one why we're not
dividing by X or Y we're not multiplying
or we don't have a term that has X to
the second power or X to the third power
or Y to the fifth power
we just have Y to the first power we
have X to the first power we're not
multiplying x and y together like we did
over here so if every if every term in
your equation on either side of the
equation is either a constant or it's
just some number times X just X to the
first power or some number times Y and
you're not multiplying your X's and Y's
together you are dealing with a linear
equation